de la contestación a la constitución
la académica mapuche elisa loncón y su
historia al convertirse en la presidenta
de la convención constitucional que
redactará una carta magna en chile su
victoria fue ampliamente celebrada has
puesto que ella académica lingüista e
inmisión activista mapuche la etnia
indígena mayoritaria del país encarna
valores de un nuevo chile esta
convención que hoy día me toca presidir
transformar a chile en un gil a
plurinacional
en la convención conformada por 155
miembros y la primera paritaria del
mundo tendrá la misión de encarrilar a
un país fuertemente afectado por una
crisis social e institucional
[Música]
para poder vivir
los compañeros mapuches
las compañeras
[Música]
lo que también marcó esta jornada fue un
grupo de constituyentes que se negó a
tomar asiento al comienzo del acto
exigiendo el cese de lo que denominaron
la represión policial contra un grupo de
manifestantes que se encontraba a las
afueras del recinto el encuentro fue
suspendido durante casi una hora
obviamente que queremos hacer una fiesta
de la democracia en un problema en
consecuencia yo voy a pedir un par de
minutos para que se informe cuál es la
realidad que estaba ocurriendo a partir
de este domingo el órgano trabajará
durante un máximo de un año para
redactar una propuesta de constitución
que deberá someterse en 2022 a otro
plebiscito con voto obligatorio
[Música]